I've never vlogged
before, so this is funny.
I hope I'm doing this right.
(upbeat music)
I moved to Los Angeles from
Oklahoma a few years ago,
and I just had a really
deep desire to be a director
but was utterly terrified to break into
such a male-dominated industry.
I was very lucky to get
an internship at Buzzfeed,
and after about a year total of begging
to be on the creative team,
they finally let me.
I get to go around the country
and direct videos, which
is an absolute dream.
And so this weekend I'm going to Chicago.
While I'm there I'm going to be vlogging
five pieces of advice about what it's like
to be a woman breaking into
a male-dominated field.
Binks!
Hi, honey.
I'm procrastinating packing for Chicago
so instead I'm gonna do my first vlog.
My first piece of advice
is to trust your vision.
It means trusting the vision that you have
for yourself and for your future.
For years I could not
call myself a director,
because I felt like an imposter.
I have pink hair, I'm very young,
you know...I'm not a dude.
After awhile I was like,
"This is really silly
because I am a director,
and that's what I do."
Once I started trusting that
vision and really believing it,
other people started believing it.
It starts with you believing
it first and trusting in that,
and then the rest will follow.
Okay, will someone come pack for me,
because I really hate packing.
(light, upbeat music)
Good morning from Chicago.
I'm up very early, getting
ready for my shoot.
Number two is you take
care of yourself first.
Just because you are a woman,
perhaps in a male-dominated field,
that doesn't mean that
you can't be a woman.
On set, I'm in tennis shoes,
my hair is usually up,
I'm usually very sweaty and disgusting.
But whenever there is a break
I usually do go to the restroom
and reapply my lipstick.
I used to be a little embarrassed
about that kind of stuff, but not anymore.
Whenever I travel, I bring
my whole skin-care routine.
I bring my Whips, my Olay Whips.
It just makes me feel more confident,
and I think it makes me a better director
whenever I show up feeling good.
Whatever it is that you
like, you should do that,
and you should take care of yourself,
because those are gonna
yield the best results.
Number three: Plan ahead.
Unfortunately, I think as a woman,
if you are not fully buttoned up it's very
easy for other people to assume
that you are underqualified.
Do the research, do your homework,
take the detailed notes,
whatever it is you need to
do to go above and beyond.
Don't ever give anyone a reason to say
that you don't know what you're doing.
Because you do.
(water splashing)
I wanted to give my
fourth piece of advice,
which is to be vocal,
and I think this one can be
tough for women, especially me.
If someone is speaking over you
or steamrolling a task
that you were assigned to,
it is okay to say, "Hey, excuse me,
"I actually wasn't finished speaking."
If you do that in a polite,
professional manner,
and they're offended by you
speaking up for yourself,
that's not your problem.
Because if you don't speak
up for yourself, who's gonna?
(upbeat techno music)
I just got home from Chicago.
I am running on three hours of sleep,
actually very surprised that
my skin looks this good.
But I wanted to give you
my final piece of advice.
Number five would to be listen well.
I personally have kind of a
bad habit of walking around
a little bit like, "I know what I'm doing,
"and I don't need help from anybody."
You never know when someone else's idea
is going to help you,
or teach you a lesson,
or make your idea even better.
And remember: It's okay to say no.
Listen first,
and then if someone's idea
doesn't align with what you want,
then you can say no.
I would just encourage always
being humble and open-minded,
because no one's ever gotten very far
in this world all alone.
(upbeat, happy music)
This all comes straight from my mother.
These are all things that she has told me.
I wanna leave this video just hoping that
some of what I've said can help
at least one other
young woman in the world
who has big dreams and wants to break into
some sort of male-dominated industry,
or any industry, whatever
it is you wanna do.
I hope some of...
I'm getting emotional!
I did not think that would happen.
Keep empowering one another,
keep being nice, keep listening well,
and keep being the boss
ladies that you are.
Goodbye, this has been very fun.
This has been a great
first vlogging experience.
So, cut.
(upbeat, happy music)
(sign creaking)